i only eat meat i've only been eating
meat since december 2017. i've managed
to put severe juvenile idiopathic
arthritis into remission i had my hip
and ankle replaced when i was 17. i was
taking a slew of medication injecting
myself with biologics immune
suppressants painkillers and i was
slowly or actually rather rapidly dying
i went to school for biomedical science
and i started researching and i came
across evidence that gluten could be
seriously inflammatory to some people
and relatively inflammatory to most
people and i did some genetic testing
and i found out i probably had celiac
disease which is an autoimmune disorder
that just is exacerbated by eating
gluten and i thought oh my god maybe
gluten is actually behind all of my
autoimmune problems when i found out
there was a link between gluten and
potential like gut damage and health
problems that blew my mind so then i
went took a deep dive into diet and i
went on a paleo diet i put my arthritis
into remission in a month of doing a
strict paleo diet